[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Thank you very much, Judy.
And I'd just like
to start by thanking
the people who run the fellows
program and the other fellows.
It's really been an
opportunity of a lifetime
for me to interact
with the other scholars
in such diverse
fields this year.
So the subject of my talk
today has to do with the ways
that genetic information is
processed in living cells.
And as Judy mentioned,
it turns out
that it's processed by
machines, machines so tiny
that they are made up
of individual molecules.
And so in my talk today,
I'm going to just remind you
a little bit about how the
flow of genetic information
in live cells happens.
And then what I'm
going to do is I'm
going to pick as an example one
particular molecular machine
that's responsible for
part of this process
and tell you a little bit
not only about what we've
discovered about how
it works, but about how
we're able to study such tiny
machines in the laboratory.
And at the end of
my talk, I'll just
spend a few minutes
talking about why
we think this kind of
research is important
and what it can be
used for in the future.
So the biological world is
a fascinating and beautiful
place.
The diversity of plants and
animals that we see around us
is a major theme in the
biblical story of creation,
and it's something that's
fascinated visual artists
and authors for centuries.
When the first light microscopes
were discovered and started
to be used by biologists,
people quickly
found out that this
incredible diversity
of different forms of
life is recapitulated
at the microscopic level.
So the early microscope
users discovered
this fantastic and
bizarre variety
of different forms
of microorganisms.
And we see the same
sort of diversity
when we look at the
cells in the human body.
There are many different
kinds of cells in the body
with different shapes,
seemingly specialized
for different
biological functions.
But when we go to even
smaller size scales,
when we go below the
level of individual cells
and we start to look at the
molecules that make up cells,
we start to see
something different.
We now know that at
the core of cells,
there's a fundamental
system of molecules
and that that
system is universal.
That is, it is true for every
living cell in every organism
on this planet.
This is that system.
It's the system by which
genetic information
is encoded and processed
in individual molecules.
And so I'll just remind you of a
little high school biology now.
So you all know that genetic
information is stored in DNA.
DNA has this long,
string-like molecule,
which I'm just showing you
a little piece of here.
It's made up of four
building blocks,
indicated by the pairs of
colors here, called base pairs.
And the genetic
information is encoded
in the sequence of those
building blocks, which
building block is
present at which
particular position in DNA.
And in human cells, there is
a lot of genetic information.
There are six billion
base pairs of DNA.
And a consequence
of that is that even
though the DNA in your cells
and the DNA in the person
who's sitting next to you, the
sequence of building blocks
is more than 99% identical.
That fraction of
1% that's different
is enough to ensure that
your genetic information is
different from the genetic
information of the person
sitting next to you, unless that
person is your identical twin.
And it is, in fact, different
from every other one of the 7
1/2 billion people in
the human population.
And of course, the DNA in all
of your cells is identical.
And the reason
that it's identical
is due to this process indicated
by the circular arrow here.
We all started out as
a single fertilized egg
cell, which divided and
divided and divided again.
And with every cell division,
a copy of the DNA molecules
is made, preserving the
genetic information,
and one copy is passed to
each of the progeny cells.
And I'm highlighting this
arrow because the process
that this arrow represents is an
information processing process.
It's a simple process.
It's just taking the genetic
information in one DNA molecule
and making an
identical copy of it.
But it's an information
processing process
nevertheless.
The same thing is true
of the processes that
use the genetic information,
which are illustrated
down here on the slide.
The DNA in our
chromosomes is divided up
into short segments,
which constitute genes.
And for the genetic
information to be used,
the first thing that happens
is that cells take each gene
and they now make a copy of
the genetic information in that
gene that is realized in a
new kind of molecule that's
very similar to DNA, RNA.
Like DNA, RNA, it's a
long, string-like molecule.
It has four building blocks.
And again, there is an
information transfer process
that allows the cell
to make many RNA
copies of the same
short segment of DNA
to amplify the genetic
information in the DNA.
And finally, the genetic
information in some of the RNAs
is converted into another
long, string-like molecule,
protein molecules, again, making
many copies from a single RNA.
The information processing
here is a little bit more
complicated, but only a little.
And that's because proteins have
20 building blocks, not just
four.
But the sequences of
these building blocks
is encoded in triples of
the RNA coding blocks.
So this scheme that I'm
showing you on the slide,
it resembles a computer
program, or the flowchart
of a computer program.
That is, it specifies
that information
is stored in a
certain physical form
and that the information
is transferred or copied
into other physical forms.
So what I'm showing you here
is essentially software.
It illustrates the
sort of program
of the genetic information flow.
And like the
software that you use
on your phone or your computer,
just having the software
is not enough.
To do any kind of real life
information processing task,
you not only need the software.
You need the hardware
that it runs on.
And the hardware that
this program runs on
is the molecular
machines that carry out
these processes
that are represented
by the highlighted arrows.
So I'm going to focus
for most of my talk
on one of these processes.
And that's the
process that carries
out this step, the steps that
reads the segment of the DNA
molecule that consists
of a single gene
and builds an RNA
a molecule that
contains a copy of that
genetic information.
And so as I indicated at
the beginning of the talk,
this process is carried out
by a tiny molecular machine.
And this is the
molecular machine here.
[LAUGHTER]
So up here, I'll put a picture
of it so you can see it better.
There it is.
So this is a molecular
machine called RNA polymerase.
It's called that because
it makes RNA polymers.
And of course, the real
one isn't this big.
This is a 3D-printed
molecular model
that was made by a Brandeis
undergraduate, Eduardo
Beltrame.
And this is a scale model.
And so the real RNA
polymerase molecule
is made out of protein,
not out of plastic.
And it is 15 million times
smaller than this model.
So it's small enough
that it is way,
way smaller than the
smallest bacterial cell.
And of course, it has to be
because a whole bunch of these
have to fit inside every cell.
So just to give you a feeling
for the scale of the process,
this is a model
of a DNA molecule
printed to the same scale.
This DNA molecule model
has 50 of the base
pair building blocks of DNA.
So this model represents a
DNA that is actually far, far
shorter than a typical gene.
So a typical human
gene might have
somewhere between 10 or 15,000
of the DNA building blocks.
So it's 1,000 times the length
of the one in this model.
And some of the
longer human genes
are 50,000 times the length
of the one in this model.
So if I tried to make a
model on the scale of one
of those large human
genes, I could lay it down
on Mass Avenue, and it would
stretch from Harvard Square
to Central Square.
And so you have to think
about the Herculean task
that this machine
has to accomplish.
In some ways, it is
like the little engine
that could that Judy mentioned.
You could imagine something of
this size plunking itself down
on the DNA in Harvard Square
and moving along all the way
to Central Square, assembling
from its building blocks
a new RNA molecule
that contained
a copy of the genetic
information that's in the DNA.
And for those long human
genes, that process in the cell
takes tens of hours
to accomplish.
And just another
thing, just to give you
an idea of the size scale,
if you look at this model
close up-- and I invite you to
come up afterwards and handle
it.
You can hold it in
your own hands--
you'll see that it's
actually an agglomeration
of little spherical shapes.
And each one of
those little spheres
represents an atom,
one of the carbon,
nitrogen, oxygen, or sulfur
atoms that make up the machine.
So this is a machine
that performs
this complex information
processing process.
And it's a machine that is so
small that when you look at it,
you can see the individual
atoms of which it is composed.
So we want to understand
how this machine works.
Can we look at it and
tell how it works?
The answer is no.
I certainly can't.
And there are
multiple reasons why
merely looking at the machine
does not tell us how it works.
And one of the most
fundamental ones
is that if we looked
at an automobile engine
and took it apart, even
if we didn't know very
much about cars,
we might very well
be able to infer what
some of the parts do.
And that's because
an automobile engine
is made by human engineers
with an intended purpose.
And human engineers
tend to design things
in a rational way, where
different parts perform
different functions, and
they get assembled together.
This machine was not
designed by human engineers.
It was designed by this
chaotic process, the process
of random mutation and
natural selection, which
causes biological evolution.
And that process works
in very different ways
than the rational thought
processes of human engineers.
And so there aren't
independently
functioning parts
of the machine.
Very often, particular
functions aren't
localized in particular
parts of the machine,
but they're
distributed all over.
And so just the
intellectual problem
of understanding how
it works is somewhat
subtle and challenging.
There's another reason
why we can't really--
these structures
are very valuable.
But there's another reason
why the structures alone
are not sufficient to tell
us how the machine works.
And that's because the
scientific methods that
produce the information that's
used to build models like this,
which I won't tell
you about today,
those methods produce a static
snapshot of the machine.
And what these protein machines
really do it is highly dynamic.
There's a great deal of
movement of the different parts
of the machine.
And understanding
that movement is
essential to understanding
the operation.
And we can't get it
from a static picture.
So as I say, these
machines are tiny.
When we go into the lab,
it's no problem for me
to put in a little teeny test
tube, a tiny drop of liquid
that does not just
contain billions
of copies of this machine.
It's easy to make
one that contains
billions of billions of copies.
And if we also put DNA into
the machine and the building
blocks of RNA, we
can get the machine
to make RNA in the test tube.
One of the fundamental
problems that we
face in studying
a system like that
is that in this large
population of molecules,
the different molecules
are doing different things
at the same time.
Every molecule is in
its own distinct phase
of the cycle through which
the machine makes an RNA.
And unfortunately, the tools
that chemists and biochemists
use to study large systems of
molecules are such that usually
what they do is they tell
us about some property
of the sample averaged over all
of the molecules in the system.
And that creates a
great deal of difficulty
in interpreting
the data in terms
of the operation of these
biological machines.
It's as if you were
confronted with a crowd
of very excited Red Sox fans.
So here's a group of
excited Red Sox fans.
The Red Sox just won
the World Series.
They're far too excited to
chant anything in unison.
And so if we try to understand
what the crowd is saying
all together, it's hopeless.
We just hear--
[CACOPHONY OF VOICES]
So if we wanted to
really understand
what they're
cheering, the only way
we could conceivably do this
is to somehow focus down
on the individual members
of the crowd one at a time.
Then--
- Yay, Red Sox!
[LAUGHTER]
- We can understand
what they're saying.
And we cannot only understand
Then we could go to a
different member of the crowd,
and we could ask if they
were saying the same thing.
- Yay, Red Sox!
[LAUGHTER]
- And there might
be somebody else who
was conveying the same general
idea in a different way.
- Woo!
[LAUGHTER]
- And there could be
somebody who is saying
something completely different.
- Ball game over!
Yankees win!
- And so it's the same
thing with our molecules.
What we really need to
do is we really need
a way to look at the
molecules one at a time
so we can build up a
representative picture
of the way the
molecules function.
But if we have to look
at them all at once,
we're kind of lost.
And this might seem like
kind of an obvious point.
And the reason that
I'm emphasizing it
is that up until a little
bit more than 25 years ago,
it was not possible
to do experiments
where we could actually look
at these individual molecular
machines one at a time
and study their function.
But at about that
time, I and several
of the other
investigators in the field
started to work out ways where
we could actually narrow down
on the functioning of
individual molecules.
And I'm going to
tell you a little bit
about those experiments now.
And I'm going to
start by telling you
about the very first one
of those experiments,
just because it sets the
stage, and it's relatively easy
to understand.
And before I tell you
about the experiment,
there's a physical
phenomenon that you
need to understand to understand
how the experiment works.
And that's the phenomenon
of Brownian motion.
So if you take any
kind of a collection
of tiny macroscopic objects that
are floating around in liquid
and you look at them
in a light microscope,
you see something
that looks like this.
So you see this kind of
random, chaotic motion.
Now, I want to emphasize
that there is nothing
living in the sample that
you're looking at right now.
This is just a video taken
through a light microscope.
And the only thing
that's in the sample
is water and a collection
of equally sized
microscopic plastic beads made
out of the same kind of plastic
that Styrofoam drinking
cups are made out of.
And so there's
nothing alive here.
We're not supplying
any kind of energy.
And yet, all of these
objects are moving.
And this is called
Brownian motion.
It's named after Robert
Brown, an English botanist who
observed the same kind
of motion in the movement
of microscopic
pollen grains that he
observed under the microscope.
And we know exactly what
is causing this motion.
And the reason why we know
it is because of this guy,
Albert Einstein, who,
for his PhD thesis,
showed that you actually expect
this kind of motion just based
on physical first principles.
And to understand
what's going on here,
I'll show you a modern
computer simulation.
So this yellow circle
represents the bead.
And the small black dots
represent water molecules,
which are floating around here.
But of course,
you can't see them
because they are too small.
And the water molecules
are exhibiting
this chaotic, random motion.
And that's just
because this sample
is at a temperature above the
absolute zero of temperature.
So the random motion
of water molecules
is the thermal kinetic energy
of the water molecules.
And at any given
instant in time,
water molecules are colliding
with the beads on all sides
at random.
But there is a
statistical effect here
where, at any given
instant in time,
slightly more water
molecules might
collide with the bead
on one side than collide
with the bead on the other side.
And that gives the bead a little
random push in one direction.
And what you're seeing here
is the residual statistical
variation where the
water molecules colliding
on all sides don't
quite even out.
OK, so now back to the
molecular machines.
So I'm going to show you a movie
of an experiment in which I
and my collaborators--
Mike Sheetz, Bob Landick,
and Dorothy Schafer--
did quite a long time ago.
What we did was we took an
RNA polymerase molecule.
We let it move down
a DNA, making an RNA.
And then we made it
stop by taking away
the building blocks of the
RNA so that it gets stuck
and it can't move.
And then what we did was we
attached the RNA polymerase
molecule to a glass
microscope slide
so it's fixed in position.
And at the other
end of the DNA, we
put one of these
microscopic plastic beads,
the same kind of bead that I
showed you in the last slide.
And when we look at
a sample like this,
we see the following.
OK?
So each one of
these little dots is
one of the microscopic beads.
They're exhibiting the
same kind of random motion
that I showed you in
the previous slide.
But here, the random
motion is subtly different.
They're not just
wandering around randomly.
Instead, they're just
sitting in one place
and jiggling randomly.
And of course, the
reason for that
is that these are
beads on a leash.
The DNA molecule is flexible.
And so the beads
can move around,
but they can never go too far.
So now, what I
showed you before,
again, the RNA
polymerase is stopped.
It's not doing anything
because we haven't given it
the building blocks of RNA.
But now, we can throw
those building blocks in.
We throw in these chemicals,
nucleoside triphosphates,
that are used to construct RNA.
And in the next slide, I'll
show you one of these beads
and what happens with time.
So at the beginning, you
noticed that bead in the center
is jiggling rapidly.
But as time goes by,
you'll see the amount
of jiggling gradually gets
less and less and less
until in another few seconds,
it will be barely moving at all.
OK?
And of course, what's going
on here is shown here.
The beads started
out on a long leash.
But in this
experiment, now we've
given it the
ingredients for RNA.
The RNA polymerase is making
RNA and moving along the DNA.
But here, the tail
is wagging the dog.
We've stuck the RNA
polymerase to the surface.
And so now the DNA has
to move through it.
And as the DNA moves through
it, the leash gradually
gets shorter and shorter.
And we see the
effect in the moving.
So this movie is not
going to win any Academy
Awards for Best Documentary.
There's no plot and certainly
no character development.
But when we made this movie,
I and my collaborators
were incredibly
excited because we
realized that for
the first time,
we were actually able
to see an individual one
of these molecular
motors moving along DNA,
or at least see the effects.
And by measuring the amount
of wiggling of the bead,
we could essentially deduce the
position of the RNA polymerase
on the bead.
And from that, we could
and did learn a great deal
about the effects of
different sequences
in the DNA on the movement, the
effects of different signals
in the DNA that control the
movement of the polymerase,
what kinds of forces the
polymerase could exert
on the DNA, and other things.
But this was a long time ago.
So now, I want to fast
forward to the present
and tell you about the
kinds of experiments
that we do nowadays to
learn more about how
these machines operate.
And these experiments,
they're motivated
by wanting to overcome a
limitation of this kind
of experiment, which is that
here, we're really only looking
at one aspect of the system.
We're just studying the position
of the polymerase on the DNA.
And these biological systems
are quite complex for reasons
that I'll tell you a little
bit more about in a minute.
We want to be able to
look at more than one
of the molecules
that's involved.
And our solution to
that is to use color.
So here's an experiment that
was done relatively recently
by my colleague, Larry Freidman.
And what Larry did was he did
the same sort of experiment.
He took a glass
microscope slide.
This time, he attached the
end of a DNA molecule to it.
And the DNA molecule
has attached to it
a single molecule of
a blue colored dye
so that when we look in a
fluorescence microscope,
we can see a little spot of
blue fluorescence from the DNA.
And the nice thing
about this technique
is that then we can
use the same approach.
We can stick dye molecules
of different colors
on each of the other
molecules that are involved.
And we can study
the coordination
of the different
molecules as they operate.
So in this particular
experiment,
Larry had blue DNA molecules.
And he looks in the
microscope, and he
sees a bunch of blue spots.
And each one of those blue
spots represents a single DNA
molecule.
And then in solution,
he could put
RNA polymerase that's labeled
with a yellow dye molecule.
And then when he looks at the
same area of the microscope
slide, but now looking at
the wavelengths of light that
correspond to the
yellow fluorescence,
he sees a series
of yellow spots.
And sure enough,
those yellow spots
line up with the
positions of blue spots,
showing him that the RNA
polymerase molecule has
come down, and it's
bound to the DNA,
and it's gotten ready to
make an RNA copy of the DNA.
And then, when Larry feeds in
the building blocks of RNA,
he adds this
red-labeled molecule,
which binds to and
helps us detect the RNA.
And he sees red spots.
And those overlay
with the yellow spots.
And so here, what
we've done is now
we're watching the whole
molecular process that's
involved in
manufacturing the RNA.
We're watching the DNA.
We're watching the
RNA polymerase.
And we're watching the
production of the RNA.
And this is just a movie
of this experiment.
So here, these
squares mark places--
so you're seeing two copies
of the exact same area
of the surface of the slide.
But one is imaged
at the wavelength
that corresponds to where the
RNA polymerase molecules are.
One is imaged at the
wavelength that corresponds
to where the RNA molecules are.
And so you can see
that at the beginning,
we start to see RNA
polymerase molecules appear
at different places.
They appear and disappear.
This turns out to be real, so
not all associations of the RNA
polymerase make an RNA.
But gradually, we see a gradual
accumulation of RNA spots
at the locations where
an RNA polymerase
molecule has made an RNA.
And we've learned a
lot from experiments
like this about the
factors that control
when an RNA is made from a
gene and when it's not made.
So the picture that emerges
from experiments like this
is illustrated by
this animation,
where the RNA
polymerase in green
is moving along the DNA in pink.
And it's spewing out the RNA
copy of the genetic information
in yellow.
And in this movie, these
little yellow spots
that are flying
around are supposed
to represent the
building blocks that
are being assembled
by the RNA polymerase
into a mature RNA molecule.
And so this animation is fun
to watch, but it's wrong.
OK?
And in several ways.
One of the ways that
you already know.
If this was a realistic
animation, on this scale,
these molecules would be
undergoing absolutely, wildly
chaotic Brownian motion.
In fact, the smaller the
molecules are, the more chaotic
the Brownian motion is.
And so the smooth motion
is a complete fiction.
And actually, the task that
a machine like this faces
is not so much how to
move along the DNA,
because movement at this scale
is absolutely ubiquitous.
What the machine has to do
is to control the movement
so it moves unidirectionally.
The other thing that's
unrealistic about this movie
is the fact that RNA
polymerase and DNA and RNA
are the only molecules
that are shown here.
And it is of course true--
I already told you that
you can take a test tube
and put RNA polymerase and DNA
and the building blocks of RNA
and you can make RNA
in that test tube.
But that's not the way
RNA gets made in the cell.
So RNA polymerase,
just like your car,
comes along with a
lot of accessories.
And unlike your
car, the accessories
aren't built in to the machine.
The accessories are just kind
of floating around in the cell,
and they interact with
RNA polymerase at random.
And those accessories are
very important because they
control all sorts of
processes in the cell.
So this is a simple example.
OK?
So this shows the
accessory proteins
that are present in the
simple intestinal bacterium E.
coli that are involved in
controlling the movement of RNA
polymerase as it
moves along the DNA.
So the RNA polymerase is
floating around in the cell.
These accessory proteins are
We know a lot about what the
individual accessory proteins
do.
But what scientists so far
have been unable to figure out
is how they collectively
function together
to modulate the behavior
of the RNA polymerase.
And that's simply because
in the systems where you're
looking at many
molecules at a time,
it's too complicated to
discern what's going on.
But now, because we can do these
single molecule experiments
with individual
proteins each labeled
with a different
color of dye, we
can start to learn about
how these proteins work.
And so here's an example
of an experiment like this.
So this is the same
sort of experiment here.
We've got DNA on the surface.
We've got RNA polymerase
labeled with a red dye
so we can see where
the DNA molecules are
at the beginning
of the experiment.
Sorry, the RNA is
labeled with the red dye.
So at the beginning
of the experiment,
there is no RNA
after a little while.
A few seconds, we
start making RNA.
And what we've
done here is we've
taken one of these
accessory proteins, which
goes by the euphonious
name of GreB,
and we've labeled it
with the green dye.
And we've watched
the GreB protein
coming and sticking on the RNA
polymerase for a little while
and then leaving.
GreB is an important
protein in this bacterium.
It's a protein
that the cell uses
to solve a particular serious
problem, which is that RNA
polymerase, every
now and then, it's
moving along copying the
genetic information in DNA,
and it makes a mistake.
And it sticks on
the end of the RNA
the wrong RNA building block.
And when that happens,
it's a big problem
because it jams up the works,
and the polymerase stops.
And if nothing were done
about that stopped polymerase,
it's a potentially fatal
problem for the cell
because the polymerase
is sitting on a gene
and it's blocking other
polymerases from moving along
the gene.
And if nothing is
done about that
and the gene is an essential
gene, the cell will die.
So GreB is the
proofreading protein.
What it does is it comes along--
and some people had
previously thought
that it rides along with
the polymerase all the time.
But we couldn't figure out
how that could possibly be,
because it would interfere with
some of those other proteins
binding to the polymerase.
Some people thought
that GreB had
a way of sensing from a distance
whether the RNA polymerase had
made a mistake and only came up
to interact with those proteins
that needed proofreading.
But what this experiment
shows is that the GreB protein
is what one of my post-docs
calls the helicopter parent
of transcription factors.
That is, it works by a
just checking mechanism.
You can see, here's
the fluorescence
from GreB molecules.
And each of these little blips
represent a GreB molecule
coming and sticking on the
polymerase for just a second
and then leaving.
And what Larry Tetone,
my PhD student,
was able to show
in this experiment
is that the GreB comes and
goes exactly the same way
if the polymerase needs
proofreading as if it
doesn't need proofreading.
So what it's doing is it's
just coming in and checking
periodically and
fixing the problem
if something needs to be fixed.
Then otherwise, it just leaves.
And in this way, it
can operate, but not
interfere with the other
proteins that also have
to bind to the RNA polymerase.
So
So here, we're just
looking at one protein.
But now, we've started to look
at proteins in twos and threes
so we can see how
they work together.
And as I and Judy
alluded to, this process
is made possible by
microscopes that we've
built at Brandeis that have
the unique capability of being
able to look at multiple colors
of single molecule fluorescence
at the same time very accurately
so that we can build up
descriptions of the processes.
This is a picture of part
of one of our microscopes.
This microscope has four visible
color lasers, red, green,
orange, and blue, and
then your infrared laser
that you can't see.
And so we're doing
experiments where we
monitor four proteins at once.
And we can potentially do more
as we develop the technology.
And we really want to
develop the technology
because what I've told
you about are just
examples of very simple
systems of accessory proteins
that regulate RNA polymerase.
Here's a more complex example.
Each one of the
circles in this diagram
represents a gene or a
set of genes in E. coli.
And the red and green
lines that connect them
show the regulatory
interactions.
They show that this
yellow protein switches
on or off the protein
that it's connected
to with either a
green or a red line.
And these processes of
switching on and off proteins
are central to biology.
They are the processes that
cause different genes to be
turned on and off in
different cell types
so that muscle cells are
different from nerve cells.
They are essential to the
processes by which cells
respond to chemical signals
in their environment
and regulate their metabolism.
And these regulatory systems
are the things that sometimes
fail in diseases like cancer.
And so we're very
interested in studying
these regulatory interactions.
There aren't enough
colors in the spectrum
for us to be able
to study all or even
a large number of these
proteins at the same time.
But you notice that if you
look at these individual nodes
that many of the
genes shown in blue
are regulated by a
relatively small number
of these regulatory proteins.
So we can hope to
make some progress
in understanding the mechanisms
by which these regulation
systems work.
My lab has mostly worked
on studying transcription
in bacteria, just
because bacteria
are a little bit simpler
than animal and plant cells.
And even though they are simpler
than animal and plant cells,
they are plenty complex,
and they could probably
keep us busy, certainly
for the rest of my career.
But kind of inspired by the
opportunity at the Radcliffe
Institute, we were also trying
to take a bold leap forward
and transplant these
technologies to use
them to study the cells
of higher organisms.
And so in my project
this year, I'm
working with Grace Rosen, one
of my students at Brandeis,
and my collaborators at Harvard
Med School, Steve Buratowksi,
Inwha Baek, and Yoo Jin Joo.
And we're making quite a
bit of exciting progress
transplanting these techniques
from simple bacterial systems
and using them to
study higher organisms.
And so I'm almost out of time,
so I'll finish up the talk
just by saying a
little bit about why
we're doing this
kind of research
and why I think it matters.
So I've talked to you today
about these molecular machines
whose operation is essential
to the viability of all living
organisms.
And understanding these
networks of protein interactions
like I showed you on the
slide of the bacteria
and how these
machines work together
to allow living
cells to function
is really one of the major
intellectual challenges
of current day biology.
It's certainly a
part of human nature
to be curious about
how life works.
And I really hope that
I've conveyed to you
the tremendous excitement
that I and other scientists
feel now that we are
making rapid progress
on these challenges through
these new kinds of experiments
that allow us to
directly observe
the operation of
individual molecules
as they go about their business.
I want to emphasize, however,
that this kind of research
does more than just satisfy
our intellectual curiosity.
I'm a fairly old guy.
And during my
lifetime, there have
been enormous advances
in our ability
to treat disease
and fight infection.
And these advances,
they are things that
do not come about in isolation.
Instead, most major advances
in these areas of medicine
were built on a foundation
of basic knowledge
about biology, exactly the
sort of knowledge that's
produced by research
projects of the type
that I've been
telling you about.
And there are
particularly good reasons
to think that today's research
on cellular information
processing mechanisms will help
future advances in medicine,
and maybe not even
that far in the future.
So even as I speak today, there
are multiple drug companies,
including a couple
right here in Cambridge,
who are starting early clinical
trials on new types of drugs
that are based on RNAs, where
they're actually administering
to patients--
yeah, they're are
clinical trials,
so I guess they're giving to
patients already drugs that
are based on modified RNAs
whose goal is to temporarily
reprogram these information
transfer processes to overcome
infections and other
kinds of diseases.
It's very early days on
these kind of medicines.
We don't know yet whether
these approaches will work.
But the early results
are sufficiently
promising that these
companies are investing
some serious amounts of
money into testing out
these new therapies.
And in the case of one
of the companies, Sirius,
it means $2 billion.
So despite the willingness of
these drug and biotechnology
companies to invest money
when a product is in sight,
they are not in general
able to put money
into research like
the work that I've
described, research
that aims to increase
the basic foundational
knowledge of the field.
And the reason for
that is very simple.
It's impossible to predict,
when this kind of research
is being done, what
its applications will
be three or five or 10
years down the road.
So if we left the funding
of that kind of research
to drug companies, as has
been proposed by some,
we would lose out
on this kind of
basic foundational knowledge.
This kind of
research would barely
happen at all were it not for
a collective decision that's
made by you and me and
our fellow citizens,
both here in the United States
and in many other countries,
to invest a small fraction
of our tax dollars
into supporting this kind
of basic research, which
contributes to the common good.
And I feel extraordinarily
fortunate to live in a society
where that decision
has been made
and where people take this
kind of enlightened view
of basic research.
And I try to remember that every
day that we go into the lab.
Thank you so much for
coming this afternoon.
And I'd welcome the opportunity
to hear what you have to say.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]